welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
bio-rad unity is a solution for
molecular quality control data
management it is presented by Dwayne
Newton PhD director of the clinical
microbiology laboratory associate
director in the division of clinical
pathology and professor of pathology at
the University of Michigan my name is
Julie L Roark and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
bio-rad laboratories for more
information about our sponsor visit
www.opm.gov/life as many questions as
you want during the presentation simply
click on the ask a question box located
in the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits no that
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Newton I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You Judy
and thanks everyone for joining us today
and the seminar I'm happy to be
presenting so without further ado I'll
get started I just wanted to disclose to
everyone some of the support that I've
received not only from bio-rad but also
from a consulting company that works
together with bio-rad I'm on the
scientific advisory board for bio-rad
and they've also provided me and our lab
with support for some of the information
we're providing today so this topic is
really important to me and I wanted to
share with you a few points of why I
wanted to present so as you all know QA
programs are
important to ensure high quality of
testing for our patients and we have to
track QC data not only to ensure that
we're doing the right thing but there
are regulatory requirements from
organizations like for our lab College
of American Pathologists and those
organizations require daily monitoring
to ensure test accuracy and high quality
performance as well as longitudinal
monitoring to look at trends and
potentially identify biases it's
difficult to manage molecular QC data
it's very time-consuming and the rules
that have been utilized in other areas
of lab medicine aren't easily applied to
molecular diagnostics do you use CT
values do you use log data for example
and up until now there really haven't
been any commercially available products
and so the approaches that we've taken
and you'll see examples from my lab have
been very manual homegrown it's very
labor intensive and requires a lot of
effort and so that makes managing QC
data very difficult challenging and
that's why it's important to try to
identify solutions to help us with that
process so for the presentation today
what I would like to do is show you some
examples from my lab is how how we
manage this data and some of the
challenges also review some approaches
that can be taken with unity the product
from bio-rad I also finally share some
results of a small evaluation we
performed with different commercially
available external controls and how
unity was used to monitor that data but
also how the controls perform relative
to each other so a little bit about our
laboratory we're a large academic
medical center we have a 24/7
core lab and an off-site main lab which
is where I'm located today we have about
20 staff ten that are dedicated to the
molecular section and ten that rotate
from our
main microbiology lab and perform
molecular testing we have a variety of
qualitative platforms from a bunch of
manufacturers you can see some of those
here we also do viral load testing and
testing for sexually transmitted
infections so almost every platform that
you can imagine probably about 10 or 12
different platforms and just from frame
of reference are our volume of sexually
transmitted infection testing CT ng in
particular is about 40,000 tests a year
and our viral load tests CMV EBV HIV HPV
and HCV constitute about 20,000 tests a
year of our total 100,000 molecular
diagnostic tests that we perform that
give you a little bit of an idea of the
size and scope of our laboratory so the
first question that we have is how are
we monitoring QC data how can we monitor
QC data there's lots of data to to keep
track of it's very complex and it can be
difficult challenging to know when
something's actually wrong one of the
approaches that can be taken actually
comes from our colleagues in clinical
chemistry and using Westgard rules
Westgard rules are applied to assays
that have multiple quantitative controls
and viral load tests are a good example
in the molecular diagnostics area where
these rules can be applied there are
rules that are applied to determine the
acceptability of a run and as I
mentioned they've really been used in
clinical chemistry assays quantitative
clinical chemistry acid aise so applying
these rules to molecular is not easy
it's not straightforward what metrics
are we supposed to use how do we
standardize that this is can be really
problematic but I'll show you some
examples of what risk Westgard rules are
and then show you how we've applied them
in
clinical molecular diagnostics so this
chart shows examples of different rest
Westgard rules
so initially these charts are called
levey-jennings charts and the black a
thick black line in the middle is the
mean that's the expected mean of the
control that you're evaluating the green
dotted lines represent one standard
deviation around that mean the yellow
dashed lines are two standard deviations
and the solid red lines are three
standard deviations so in the box in the
upper left corner you have a run with
your control that's run and it gives you
a number in this case that is greater
than two standard deviations above the
expected mean that is the one s it's
violating that one 2's rule which is
it's a single value that's two US two
standard deviations above the mean
so that would trigger a warning it's a
yellow flag saying there might be
something going on you need to pay
attention but it wouldn't automatically
fail your run the upper right corner is
an example of a violation that would
fail a run this is one where that
control value was three standard
deviations or more above outside of the
mean that would constitute a failure and
would require some sort of intervention
depending on what your lab procedures
are another example of a violation would
be in the bottom left which is a two two
a stroll that means that you've had two
consecutive values for that control that
test at greater than two standard
deviations above our outside of the mean
and then the bottom right is for one s
rule so four in a row that are at least
one standard deviation outside of the
mean so these may or may not constitute
failures of your run but they certainly
would require some sort of intervention
and review just to determine what's
going on
these are the types of rules that can be
applied to quantitative assays and these
are the types of rules that we do apply
in our evaluation of QC data and our
laboratory the way the approach that we
take is for our viral load assays and
particularly we're going to talk mostly
about HIV viral loads from our lab today
but in general our assays have for these
quantitative tests negative controls low
positive controls and high positive
controls we historically had third party
external controls and or in-house
developed and external controls that
were used in our laboratory developed
tests as an extra run control and really
it was used to help us because they were
laboratory developed tests have an extra
level of control and help us pass our
runs but wanted to ensure that even if
there was one control that was not
performing well the more controls we had
we felt like that were in in range the
more confident we were in that
particular assay for that particular run
but those external controls were not
really used to monitor performance of
the tests over time it was just that
particular for that particular run in
establishing our data our expected data
that we would monitor for all these
controls like the quantitative values we
would generate five to ten replicates
use five to ten replicates to generate a
mean and standard deviations to then
start to put in place the rule the
evaluation of the rules that we would
use for monitoring that data and we
program Westgard rules into an Excel
spreadsheet which I'll show you in a
moment but it requires manual entry for
each run and manual review on a daily
basis one of the points I would like to
make though before we move on is that we
discontinued the use of external
controls
as a as a cost-saving measure for a
borrow load assays because you have
almost entirely all IVD assays they're
not laboratory-developed tests and and
the performance of those tests have
stabilized over time and didn't require
having an external control to ensure
that they passed but because of that
because we don't have external controls
we really don't have a good way to
monitor assay variation over time or to
make good lots a lot comparisons except
for using previous patients positive and
negative samples so that that's a manual
effort as well to collect those and and
evaluate those so this is a screenshot a
very busy screenshot which you're not
supposed to be able to see all the
values it's just to show you how complex
this process has been for us so we've
built we built this Excel spreadsheet
each line represents a different day and
a different run we manually input the
values that were obtained for that run
for the negative low and high positive
controls we manually input the lot
numbers and we manually determine
whether then the program determines
whether based on the values that we
inputted whether the run past or whether
Westgard rules were triggered and then
if any remedial action had to be taken
their comments there there's a box for
comments to be inputted and then on the
far right we have a column where there's
documentation of review of those results
so you can see there are examples that
are highlighted in yellow or red where
there were flags that were generated
there's a couple of examples of runs
that fail because of values that were
outside of acceptable rules so this next
slide is showing a couple of examples of
the levey-jennings charts that were
generated from Excel showing the data
that we were able to monitor over time
and so
similar to what I showed you a couple of
slides ago we have a mean with a thick
bar I think it's the red line through
the middle that is a rolling mean that
we're generating and you can see the
values on either side of that there are
some little hash marks that show you 1 &
2 & 3 standard deviations and then you
can also see the red dots or the yellow
dots where there's warnings or
rejections so we're reviewing these
there it can be cumbersome and not very
pretty because the way you know we're
manipulating the spreadsheet there might
be gaps in the cells because of some
changes we've made or we brought in
something new or did something different
and so the drop in the line is just a
reflection that there are no data points
in that spreadsheet so it can get ugly
from a an aesthetic standpoint so we
have these spreadsheets for all of our
quantitative assays and they're all the
data input as manual as I mentioned and
all the reviews manual so the
supervisors and our chief technologists
are going in the computer and looking at
each of these spreadsheets for all of
our assays every day and it can be it is
very time-consuming and very cumbersome
and sometimes difficult to identify when
problems are really arising or that
there are trends that we should be
paying attention to and we've been
looking for a long time for something
that provided a little more automation
or a little more standardization and
became aware of unity as a product
actually from our clinical chemistry
colleagues and it's a commercially
available product that has a variety of
features that can address that
challenges that we're facing in the lab
this product has been available for a
long time with a lot there's a lot of
experience in using it that allows us
and any other user to have a one-time
entry of the QC data for the particular
block of reagents the data entry is
pretty simple
and then at automat
Klee calculates the values the means and
tracks the variances there's also a
reduced risk for manual error because
there is interface ability of the
program with your automated instruments
that's very prevalent with chemistry
applications chemistry laboratory
applications and we're just starting
that process with bio-rad to establish
interfaces with our Abbott
instrumentation that we perform viral
load testing on because of the the
nature of the software the data review
is very streamlined and I'll show you
examples of some of the reports that are
generated and used for review so the
actual meat of the discussion for today
is really a couple of parts of a study
that we performed in our laboratory last
fall started last fall and the first
part was really looking at unity as a
data management solution and had
controls from a variety of different
manufacturers that were tested in our
HIV viral load sa using Avid m 2000 and
I just generated a bunch of data on
testing those controls and entered that
data into unity and tracked it see how
how streamlined that process was how
user-friendly it was the other part of
the evaluation was to really look at the
performance of the external controls
relative to each other and I talked
about our journey with external controls
and and decision not to use them for
cost savings purposes but I also pointed
out limitations as far as our inability
now to track in a very robust way lapped
a lot potentially lacked a lot variation
or instrument to instrument variation of
assay so using external controls and
your assays provides you with an
opportunity to do that and we wanted to
start that process of looking at how
these controls compared to each other
where
you know when they say they test out a
certain value
did they really test at that value so
the different controls that were used
were as I mentioned our assay was HIV sa
from Abbott so we had that kick controls
provided by habit allo a negative alone
a high positive we also had a product
from bio-rad that they provided for us
the athlete check one product which has
negative low and high positive controls
for multi multiple analytes including
HIV acro metrics has a multi analyte
control that is HIV HCV HPV low and high
positive sera care positive control and
then we also used a lab manufactured by
us control that was generated by pooling
plasma from a variety of spent patient
specimens and included negative low and
high positives so all of these were used
in the evaluations and I'm going to
describe forthcoming so the first part
of the study was looking at all of these
controls tested one time per run over
twenty different runs and we used over
all for the entire evaluation one lot of
the HIV assay reagents and sequestered
part of that so that the the last part
part to the study could be performed six
months later which is now so the part 1a
we had twenty separate runs where the
external controls were run one time we
looked at the comparison of the controls
to the stated values between run
reproducibility and compare center of
controls to each other and the part 1b
of the study we perform within run
reproducibility and so we had multiple
replicates of each control that were run
on one plate a loquats of those
replicates
were sequestered and stored at for at
minus 30 degrees for six months to look
at the stability of those controls over
time and then that reproducibility
experiment was repeated by our lab
recently I don't have data to share on
that unfortunately but it will be
forthcoming this is an example of this
is a screenshot from how the data entry
looks for unity and the on the first
blush it may appear well this is just as
complicated as what I showed you before
but actually it's a lot simpler and that
there are screens which I'm not showing
you where we've already inputted the
information for each of the controls
that were being used so the lot numbers
and the expected values for those sample
for the the control was provided was
inputted at the front end and then that
carries through by the program in the
background so all that we're doing is at
each line you can see line one of the
spreadsheet is the 5th of September and
we put in my technologists put in the
values that were obtained for that run
for that level of control so the box
that pops up is specific for that
control this happens to be the bio-rad
and blue check control but there is
another box for the acro metrics
controls there's another window for the
Sarah care controls and so on so each of
those are track are able to be tracked
separately and you can see at the top of
the box it tells you exactly what lap
number it is what the material is when
it expires and the rules the Westgard
rules that we've selected to be included
and then we can put in the values and as
soon as you enter the values those rules
are being applied to it and you can see
there are lots of red where there were
failures are our values out of range and
I showed this only because I wanted to
use it as an example to show how the
flags are generated but the data really
wasn't that bad we just made a mistake
when we entered the the expected ranges
we put the standard deviation range to
narrow and so a lot of the values came
out outside of those ranges when we went
back and corrected it on the data looks
much better but I kept it here for
illustrative purposes you can see how
those flags are generated the box at the
bottom shows you what the the inputted
means and standard deviations were so
are internally designed spreadsheet well
better than our previous process in
terms of labor is still less an ideal we
spent a lot of time managing QC as I
told you we had to enter that data and
manually track and process it but with
unity of a Westgard roll rejection is
triggered a pop-up box actually is
visible and the technologist has to
enter an appropriate remedial action so
not only do you see the red number
that's generated here what you are
seeing is that popup box and based on
what your laboratory procedures are
specific action needs to be put in place
based on that variation and that
basically serves as a hard stop for the
technologists they can't go any further
if there's something out of range it you
have to indicate what you're gonna do as
a result of that out of range value so
this is an example of the levey-jennings
plots for the same the same data and the
top is the negative control level one
the middle is level two and the bottom
is level three control the first way I'm
going to point out is how the flags show
up on the levey-jennings plots and so
the little red triangles that are circle
here represent those values that were
3sd out of range and so these would have
been rejected runs rejected at the time
of testing you can also see the yellow
squares which are circled here these
would be the warnings that would require
review and then at the very top you can
see the codified action the number there
represents the code and right above the
circle I think you might be able to see
it says thirty test si repeated so at
the top of the chart is a summary of all
the information and any codes that were
entered by the technologist would also
be listed here and so when that run
failed then it was repeated that's what
that number is indicated so you can see
a initial review of those charts or the
summary review of those charts what was
the intervention that occurred this also
shows you an example of how this this
particular data the level two performed
relative to the mean so this control the
expected mean the mean expected values
were point two or two point three logs
and it was generally performing higher
overall than what was provided by the
package insert the mean provided by the
package insert and so this is an example
of how you might or you should approach
calculating means internally so you the
package insert serves as a guide but you
can calculate that means using replica
testing yourself and you should do that
with each control and that's what we did
actually and this is a chart showing
that same did a recalculated using the
first five tested values to generate the
mean as opposed to relying on the
package insert' expected value and when
we did that you can see that it was
performed much better around mean we did
the same thing for the high positive
control as well and it performed very
very well
the interesting thing or the the nice
thing about unity though is that it
allows the user to determine the
approach to take when calculating means
and standard deviation so you can use
the Packard's insert data but you can
also use a data range over time or you
can use cumulative data like I just
showed you where you're taking
cumulative values from the first five
the first 10 the first 20 so the user
has the ability to customize that and
based on their approach that they want
to take in their laboratory so this
chart is an example of a report that
allows the comparison of multi multiple
levey-jennings plots at the same time
and well this example is showing
different controls so the top panel is a
serie care positive control the middle
panel are the applicant roles and the
bottom panel is the echo metrics control
you can really use a variety of
different combinations of things and and
where I see this being of most value is
in a situation where like our lab where
we have multiple mm mm instruments where
where we are running the same assays and
if you have controls that are being run
on the same instruments for example an
external control and each run the same
external control is being run on
different instruments you can track how
those controls are performing on each
instrument so you can associate one
control with a particular instrument
when you set it up and then generate
plots to compare those the performance
of those and see if there are any trends
that may be instrument 2 is showing some
diminishing values over time and while
they're still in range the use you're
seeing this trend and unless you had
those controls being run on multiple
instruments and you had a good way of
tracking it you might not actually
recognize that
another important aspect of the
functionality of this system is shown
here with this data review report this
allows you to review data for a
particular control over time so this in
this example you're looking at the
bio-rad control level one level two and
level three and this was exactly the
data that I showed you at the beginning
that had all the flags and I just
printed out or took a screenshot of that
report you can see the first one was
rejected and the third run was rejected
in this you have documentation here of
not only the values that were obtained
the action that had to happen as a
result of the rejection so in this case
the test or assay was repeated then we
have documentation of the technologist
as well as the supervisor review in this
case this is artificial because this was
a research experiment so the same person
was entering data but you have the
ability to have the technologists who
entered the data be indicated on the
right and the supervisor who's reviewing
the data indicated and on the left so
that if you're being inspected you have
the opportunity to provide information
from one source showing how these
controls perform whether it was rejected
the corrective action that was initiated
and that documentation of supervisorial
review we're in our cap window right now
and so this is going to be very helpful
for us to have one place to be able to
provide that information now I'll
transition into the part of the
discussion related to how these the
different controls that were tested
actually perform relative to each other
so the unity data shown in the previous
slides is comparing the showed examples
that compared the values that we achieve
to the expected means are within control
how that can
I'll perform based on what we expected
but we also wanted to see how the
controls perform relative to each other
trying to see where the low and high
positive controls tested that is what
values were obtained compared to the
means to each other and so this first
graph shows you how the abbot bio-rad
Syrah care and and our in-house
laboratory developed controls perform
relative to each other and so the box
indicates the legend box indicates where
we expected those values to test and the
lines are showing you where they did
test and overall all the low positive
controls tested between 100 and 1,000
copies per mil Abbot's controls with the
kit were right at where we expected them
the bio-rad low positive control was a
little above I was testing right around
2.5 logs and it was indicated to be 2.3
Syrah care was around the mean but
overall high and our
laboratory-developed was around the mean
as well but overall just a little bit on
the low side the high positive controls
abbot by rad and our in-house lab
controls were all testing right on their
expected value they performed very well
the acro metrics control was
consistently below the expected value
and about a log lower than the other
controls so I was testing about at a
level of 5,000 copies per mil versus the
other three that were in the fifty to a
hundred thousand copies per mil and so
while is labeled as a high positive
control it really tested more as a
mid-range control I'm not really sure
what the dip on run number three was
that's something that we were trying to
figure out that don't have an answer for
that and I think again what this shows
is the value of trying of calculating in
your own hands what those how those
controls
performing and not relying exactly on
what the package insert claims are this
next the next two slides are showing the
reproducibility experiment so this was
experiment 1b where we had excuse me
this is just between run reproducibility
so taking the that data that I just
showed you and calculating the percent
CVS over time so we have for the low
positive controls the expected means and
standard deviations and highlighted for
all the percent CVS for the low
positives were in the two to six percent
range there are some differences and as
you can see but for from my experience
with low positive controls where I've
seen CVS and the you know twenty to
thirty percent range sometimes I thought
these all perform very very well and I
don't think there's really any
difference between 6% and 2% when you're
talking about a hundred two thousand
copies per mill on the next slide then
is the high positive control data again
these all perform very very well not a
lot of difference in variability from
between those those controls so now is
experiment 1b where we were looking at
within run reproducibility so in this
experiment we had multiple replicates
different controls run on the same plate
in the same assay at the same time and
so the numbers and parentheses indicate
the number of replicates for each
control and again as you can see
highlighted on the right there are some
differences between the products but
overall both with the low positive
controls seen here and with the high
positive controls seen here there isn't
any real difference and
mine between those so as ice mentioned
the second part of this experiment was
looking at stability over time and
unfortunately we're calculating the data
right now my tech my research tech
performed those experiments this week
and I was not able to have that in time
for the presentation but we'll be
evaluating how stable these controls are
over six months that's what the
packaging shows and that the expected
stability is six months and we want to
evaluate that so just to go back to this
concept of external controls I mentioned
it a little bit in the beginning of the
or in the middle of the presentation
that you know are going back and forth
between using them and not using them
and really there are some there's some
good reason to use external controls you
can look at changes in assays across
reagent Lots or instruments you can
identify issues related to any matrix so
if there's some carryover within the
extraction process that doesn't remove
inhibitors or there's a problem with a
particular specimen type it's feasible
that these external controls would pick
up some test performance differences
also extremely useful to have
well-characterized standardized reagents
that are available for validation
fda-approved assays or verification of a
laboratory developed tests and I think
that you know that standardization that
convenience where you've got a
commercial commercial resource to use
really adds a lot of value and even for
laboratory developed tests first and
foremost having a commercial source for
acid controls you know low positive and
high positive controls that's really
important and it that's been an approach
that we've taken with our LD T's in the
past as well so a variety of scenarios
areas where external controls can add
value and we're looking at processes to
start to incorporate those more into our
quantitative tests so just to summarize
the discussion today I think you've seen
that there are lots of opportunities to
utilize more automated tools I'm not
sure the approaches that other labs are
taking but even you're using a Excel
approach like us it's still very
cumbersome and so any any solution that
could take the technologists back to the
bench and away from the computer
managing data I'm all for that it's a
much better use of their time being
technologists as opposed to
administrators in unity I hope I've
shown is a commercially available multi
feature option that you can use to track
and manage QC data in a very streamlined
way and as I as I mentioned the
automated capabilities when it's
interface to your instrument enhances
that ease of use and the second half of
the presentation I presented data on
different commercially available
controls that are out there at least
with the HIV viral load test that I
showed you the data from the HIV viral
load test that I showed you all these
controls perform relatively equivalently
but I think just to reinforce that
measuring those controls in your own lab
and your own hands on your own platforms
and determining what the expected value
should be is very very important
external controls and also add value as
I highlighted on the previous line to
your molecular Quality Assurance
programs and together these controls and
unity can streamline the approaches that
you take
to really functioning at a high level
and in quality assurance program in your
laboratory finally I'd like to thank a
lot of folks that helped first and
foremost Scott McClellan who's our
research and development tech we
actually ran all the experiments
generated all the data and shared that
with me so that I could present that to
you today I'd really really like to
thank the fluid from bio-rad who's
really go-to expert on unity and has
helped us tremendously and getting it
implemented in our laboratory had
finally a lot of great experience
working in partnership with bio red and
Navi DX as a consulting organization and
I really appreciate all of their support
and I thank you all for your attention
and your time and I'm really excited to
be able to answer your questions when we
have one thanks thank you dr. Newton for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank bio-rad laboratories
for making today's educational webcast
possible as a final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us we'll see you
next time goodbye